our top story this hour the human toll
of the war in ukraine according to the
ukrainian government friday nearly 200
children have been killed in the war and
at least
355 have been injured the united nations
says 90 percent of the four and a half
million people fleeing the country are
women and children as families suffer
from violence and loss one family in
ukraine is helping children heal with
the trauma through art roxanna seberry
reports
it's a otra
it's a silly city
felicity
when russia's invasion of ukraine
force the bike of its family to flee
keeve in february
six-year-old sonia took the toys she
could carry
and drew what she left behind
is that your cat yes
her art inspired her parents to collect
drawings from other ukrainian kids and
post them online for everyone to see
also we know that children want to
have appreciation to feel them like not
alone but a part of a bigger community
they feel connected yeah absolutely from
age five and up each child tells a story
say like maria 11 years old she is very
talented arena 11 years old she drew a
woman soldier yeah sniper woman yeah
it's her mother
her mother is a sniper
yeah some pictures show
real world bombs missiles
killed soldiers it's not suitable for
kids the pictures portray innocence
stolen and prayers for protection
and peace
maybe it's very hard for them to speak
about it they don't know what's going on
the drawing helps them express their
emotions
absolutely yeah
it's created like a parallel world you
know
in which you could uh feel safe artem
and nastya who are still searching for
safety in town after town across ukraine
say encouraging kids to draw can also
help parents like them
sending them to sit somewhere and turn
on their fantasy and put it on the paper
give to the parents also an opportunity
to recharge the battery and they hope
these creations will show the world the
strength and suffering of their nation
we hope that people looking on these
pictures can feel compassion to support
kids to support ukraine and to stop the
war because when the war ends they say
it's ukraine's children who will rebuild
their country
for cbs saturday morning roxanna suberi
london
rebuild and they're left with a memory
of all of this too and art therapy for a
long time
has really been helpful how they can
process yeah process all of this yeah
they need to process
they really do